easter is next sunday it's an important
day for christians of course and it's
also a traditional day for easter
baskets and candy
this year seas candies is marking a
hundred years in business with a new
store just in time for the holiday
hector mejia is there the company shows
the northwest for its fourth location
it's an area that's seeing
a lot of growth this will be the 250th
store for the chocolate maker founded in
the l.a area and headquartered now in
san francisco
according to president and ceo pat egan
chocolate's essential and we're the best
las vegas is growing as you know like
crazy and i lived here for five years
you can just see it all around you if
you're familiar with the area the newest
location is at the montecito marketplace
on north durango just south of the 95.
it's opening at a time when the iconic
company is evolving
in a way because we've been in business
for 100 years
we have a lot of the same recipes and a
lot of the same pieces that we had when
we started
in business so it's not that easy to
introduce a new piece and we're doing
12 this year and so this month is
dark chocolate peanut butter eggs around
the same time last year seas was
halting production shutting down its
stores as we dealt with the pandemic
it was the second ever closure in
company history
the first since world war ii we actually
had stores closed all the way up until
october of last year
despite those setbacks business could
not be sweeter for the company
who doesn't love chocolate we've had one
of our best januaries ever best february
ever
e-commerce has continued to stay very
high with easter right around the corner
they're opening at a great time
the grand opening is scheduled for
tomorrow reporting from the northwest dr
mejia
8 news now